we were looking at the sign rule this
morning okay
now the sign rule excuse me
you can phrase in two different ways
which are much the same
really but they are very subtly
different
in a triangle like this
the convention is to use capital letters
for the vertices for the corners
and lowercase for the lengths that are
opposite those corners okay so little a
is opposite big a and little b is
opposite big b
and so on okay so in this kind of setup
we have learned this
that a on sine a
is equal to is equal to
b on sine b which is also equal to
c and sine c and they're all they're all
equal
and because there are fractions all the
way through
we could take the reciprocals of
everything
put all the signs on top and all of the
lengths
on the bottom okay so that's true and
that's fine
but when you see something like this
when you see three things and they're
all equal to
each other it kind of implies that all
three of them
are equal to some other quantity like
they're not really equal to each other
it's just they're equal to each other by
coincidence it's because each one of
them
independently is equal to some outside
thing
right and because they all have the same
relationship
to this that's why they're all equal to
each other it's almost like a
coincidence
right it'd be a little bit like looking
at a wheel
right and it's got all these spokes
okay and you might say oh look all the
spokes are like equidistant or they're
all the same length or something like
that right
but that's kind of coincidental the fact
that it's all
attached to the center of the wheel
right so
they're only equal to each other because
they all share this
underlying geometric relationship okay
and it's exactly the same thing with the
sine rule all these three things
are equal to this thing outside of them
and um to illustrate you'll need all
these three circles
okay so hopefully you can see
that since these are all the same i'm
just going to go after
one of these prove it for one if i
proved it for one i proved it for all
the others
okay because there's symmetry to it so
if you prove it for one it's really
equivalent to proving for the rest
right so i'm thinking about a particular
kind of angle in a particular kind of
site and there are three choices
three cases three circles that i'm going
to need so
case one is where you have an acute
angle being you know investigated its
ratio with the opposite side
okay you could have an acute angle
case two i'll come back to case two
case three in triangles right if an
angle is not acute
if it's bigger than the q then it's
going to be obtuse
right but that of course
implies between case one and case three
in between a cute and a two stairs
a right angle okay
all right excuse me so we're going to
have a look at all three cases
and um they look slightly different each
time now why did we draw
these circles um each of these circles
is called has a special name
and it's not a joke
these circles are called circum circles
okay now you're like wait for real okay
uh it's like it's a circular circle so
almost
okay uh like second navigate means to go
around something
okay so a circular circle is a
particular kind of circle
that's going around another shape and
the shape we're interested in
is a triangle okay if you've got three
points one two three
they uniquely define a circle okay
so if you've got an acute angle that
you're interested in like so
use your imagination if you have an
acute angle
then that means the center of the circle
of this circle that passes through all
of the points in the triangle the center
of the circle will pass
inside the triangle so i can draw
us the center about there okay
so the center of the circum circle is
inside the triangle
okay so i'm going to use this to show
what this
a on sine a and therefore be on side b
and so on
i'm going to use that construction to
show what it's actually equal to
okay so excuse me where's a in this
diagram where is it
it's over here opposite capital a okay
there we go sorry i meant lowercase
so that length right so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to construct a
triangle around that lowercase
a all right i'm going to construct a
triangle that goes through
the center of the circle like so like
this
okay so we're doing a little bit of
circle geometry here and we shouldn't be
all that surprised
because when we first had a look at
trigonometry and moved away from like
you know trig ratios into trig functions
we saw that circles
were related all the time to triangles
and that's why the trigonometric
ratios the trig functions are often
called circular functions we went over
this
okay so i've got this side here this
triangle with
a the side i'm interested in right
and it passes through the center okay
now because it passes through the center
that length there that
cuts through right it's a diameter isn't
it okay so because it's a diameter i'm
going to label it
d diameter okay label it deeper diameter
now being that it's the diameter okay
there's an interesting thing that
happens with this angle over here let me
name it we've got a b and c i'll call
this one
capital p okay so this angle over here
in the bottom right hand corner
p b c okay does anyone know
because it's the diameter what's ppc
equal to yeah
it's 90 degrees fahrenheit now i didn't
see all the hands up
so let me very very briefly on the side
over here explain
why it's 90 degrees it's very very
simple okay
this property about circles is called
the angle in a semicircle
and the reason why is because a diameter
divides
the circle into two semicircles right
and any angle in this semicircle is
going to be equal to 90 degrees and i'll
show you why
okay so just on the side here draw a
small
circle off on the side a little bit okay
draw a diameter there okay and then draw
a triangle
any triangle you like where one of the
sides
is the diameter and the other corner
is on the circumference now because this
is
um a circle right if i join this line up
here
i've made two triangles and both of
those triangles
are isosceles can you see why why
they're isosceles
radius because i have all these radii
flying around right
i've got this side being equal to this
side so i have a nice sausage triangle
up there
and i have a different isosceles
triangle down here
okay so far so good now one of the
things you know about isosceles triangle
is that if the
sides are equal right then the angles
that are opposite those sides
will also be equal okay so for instance
i can call this angle up here alpha
which make that one out right equal
angles are opposite
equal sides you see that in the same way
because i've got this thing down here
the angles aren't the same
but they'll be the same to each other
right so i can't call it alpha because
it's a different triangle altogether but
i can call them both beta
is that any sense all right now having
labeled all these alphas and betas you
can see i've accounted
for every angle in this original
triangle that i drew
the triangle that's in the semicircle
okay so let's do the angle sum of that
big triangle i've got two alphas
and i've got two beaters right
that's all of the angles in this big
triangle so what do they add up to
180 because that's the angle sum of a
triangle and so now all i have to do is
divide by 2
to show that whatever configuration i've
got
this angle over here will be 90 degrees
can you see that
and in fact if you draw a decent circle
anywhere you put
that triangle it will get like a right
angle over there in the corner okay no
matter how far you go
it's kind of well that was you get the
idea okay so we call this the angle on
the semicircle right
okay so now while i establish p b c
that's 90 degrees and that's why
okay excuse me so now
can you see what's happening in here
what's going on
in here right our original angle
a that we're interested in is up in this
corner okay
but there's another circle property you
might remember right because of this
arc that's around here
see that arc there right i have two
angles that are what we call standing on
the same arc
right like legs standing on the side you
can see this b ac
is standing on this green arc right and
b pc same up right so therefore they
should
be equal right so if i've got a up there
i should have a
in here as well with me so far
okay so having done all of that to
establish this
and this i can now make a statement
about this
triangle here in triangle
pbc it's right angle
so i can just use my right angled
triangle trig formulas right
i can say sine a this a
not that a that's in another triangle
this a right
it's opposite on hypotenuse
right opposite on
hypotenuse you okay with that a that
original side over the
diameter so where is our bit off
where's the sine rule in this all i need
to do is switch these guys over
right so if i switch them around and put
them all on one side i should get a
one side a equals d
okay do you see what i've done this is
this ratio if i wanted to do b on sine b
or c on sine c
i just draw the triangle in a different
direction okay
but this ratio the reason why all the
ratios are equal to each other is
because they're all equal to this
the diameter of the circle that goes
through
all the points of the triangle you say
that again
this ratio that you come up in the same
room the reason all of them are
all three equal to each other is because
they're all equal to this the diameter
across
that particular circle that goes through